au choix la grogne comment briser
l'ennui qui a élu domicile chez les
aînés en isolement
les gens de la résidence rosemont les
quartiers se sont donné rendez-vous sur
leur balcon
vous employez en profite pour les
distraire c'est beaucoup d émotion de
leur voir depuis quelques jours c'est
une manière d'être et tous ensemble
depuis lundi de cette semaine la salle à
manger se permet alors les résidents et
on les sert leur est pas à l'appartement
comme tel dans la résidence les
consignes qui limite les sorties les
regroupements et les visites ne sont pas
toujours bien comprises ou faciles à
respecter
il ne faut pas seulement qu'à soi mais
tout vent sur zone et je peux vous citer
les petits ben on peut toujours belle
comme un des fils d'une nouvelle
résidente à les tâches des soins a dû
laisser son paquet à la réception la
commission aujourd'hui j'ai un ipad pour
la première fois de sa vie
facetime malheureusement est arrivé dans
un temps très difficiles et puis c'est
ce qu'on trouve le plus dur tout le jeu
de la déménager
et puis elle m'a aimée puces ont confié
à leurs champs pour le moment en
l'absence d'activités de groupe
une résidente en scène yoga et
méditation en ligne
quant à yolande dubuc cet arrière grand
mère à plein de choses à faire
sita tiges d'un terroir défi j'exécute
que j'avais ni de cour d alger par l onu
ont été mis à clignoter
mais là on voudrait à pied d'oeuvre pour
éviter par exemple comment que femme je
propose qu'on s'habille ultra chic et à
16 heures on va pouvoir écouter claude
saucier
or un des vos balcons qui risque de se
produire régulièrement désormais ici
anne louise despatie radio canada mon
frère
[Musique]